um thank you for the introduction and
um happy to be here talking to you about
um genetic solutions that we bring for
your immune oncology research
so um let's begin um by taking a look
at um what is immuno oncology a
very brief introduction so i'm going to
skip through the slide and
move on to immuno oncology um
immune oncology is that branch of
cancer therapy which uses the body's own
immune system
to trigger a response against tumor
cells
and ultimately eliminate them
in the more recent past immunotherapy
has
shown to be extremely effective in
providing a response and
sometimes complete remission for
some patients with advanced cancers um
and especially those which had patients
who had not shown
um response to treatment is chemotherapy
or rate
rate therapy because of this
immunology or immunotherapy is
considered the fifth
pillar in cancer therapy
along with radiotherapy surgery
chemotherapy and targeted
treatments what's also notable is
um immunotherapy has found to be uh
actually pretty um successful in
treating
um high advanced age cancers
when used in combination with
traditional therapies such as surgery
chemotherapy and
radiotherapy
um so what uh what makes immunotherapy
so different
well i think it can be best described
because immunotherapy or immuno oncology
uses the
adaptive immune system to recognize and
specifically attack
cancer cells um
the entire process by which this happens
can
can be easily uh described in the immune
cancer
cancer immunity cycle which was proposed
by melman chan
and can be seen in this figure here
these are a series of stepwise events
that must be initiated and allowed to
proceed
iteratively for an anti-cancer immune
response to be
effective t cells and t cell mediated
responses
are the focal point of any immuno
oncology
research so
that's a very brief overview of what
immuno oncology is
and currently the immuno oncology focus
areas can be broadly classified
into six main groups the checkpoint
inhibitors
adaptive t-cell transfers um
or cells
therapeutic cancer vaccines optic
vaccine
immunotherapy monoclonal antibodies and
cyto
cytokines for the purpose of
this talk we will focus on the first
three
focus areas that's the checkpoint
inhibitors cardi cell therapy and
therapeutic cancer vaccine
so
let's take a look at what checkpoint
inhibitors are so checkpoint inhibitors
are essentially proteins that are
present on
surface of tumor cells
uh which help uh the tumor cells to
evade body's immune system
and how do they do that they do that by
essentially fooling the immune system
into thinking
that the tumors are tumor cells or
cancer cells are self
instead of foreign and checkpoint um
inhibitors that they have are
molecules that activate the immune
system into recognizing tumor cells
foreign
and thereby causing them to eliminate uh
the tumor cells now targeted inhibition
of checkpoint inhibit
inhibitors or targeted inhibition of
checkpoint
receptors or proteins um
can enhance the response of t cells
towards the tumor and this is what is
used in checkpoint therapy immune
treatment therapy
and currently immune checkpoint
inhibitors are considered
very very important and probably the
most study targets
in immuno oncology
cancer vaccines like most of the
vaccines therapeutic cancer vaccines
trigger the immune system
into recognizing and attacking markers
or antigens that are present
uh either in or around uh cancer cells
multiple types of therapeutic cancer
vaccines
um could be you know either into
proteins whole cells or
anti-representing cells
typically the dendritic cells and
cancer vaccines often do require
additional substances such as adrenals
for
optimal effectiveness
and finally uh car t cell therapy so
what is car t cell therapy
um it's a very interesting uh molecular
mechanism
in which um
the t cells uh from from a body are
removed
um the genetically programmed to fight
cancer multiplied and then infused back
into the body
these newly programmed t cells or car t
cells
are now able to eliminate tumor cells
cells have been successfully engineered
to treat acute lymphoblastic leukemia
um when no longer response
treatments and in the past
couple of years 2017 2018 fd approved
two car t cell therapies
for b cell lymphoma and acute
lymphoblastic leukemia
and more research is being done to
further find applications of cardi cell
but
it's extremely promising so with that
i will shift gears and talk a little bit
about
what tools we have in our genetic
toolbox
from applied by systems and iron torrent
which
could be used in your immune oncology
research so here is
an overview of um
all the um all the different platforms
we have
uh within our uh genetic
analysis uh toolkit so we have solution
based on
the relative
we have solutions for pcr and uh digital
pcr
uh microarrays as well as ngs so
essentially
the whole plethora of
genetic analysis solutions so uh in the
next few slides we'll
go uh take a deeper dive into
which of these solutions can be used
used for uh
which of the immune immuno oncology
research research and and some examples
of
you know how in the past customers have
used them
all right so uh first up is checkpoint
inhibitors um
and for checkpoint inhibitor research we
have uh solutions
um which are uh in the microarray
platform
of qpcrs as well as ngs so i'll spend a
little
less time on this um and substitute one
more example and it will help you
understand how these can be used
so for microarray we have a you know a
whole transcriptome analysis panels as
well as c
c and b um assays in qpcr we have
a multitude of stack management
expression assays
uh which are present as different panels
um the pre-selected panels and they can
also be ordered as custom
gene expression panels based on your
custom requirements
and of course we have the ngs solution
where we have whole transcriptome
panels both human and mouse as well as
more targeted panels such as the
oncoming immune
response research assay or the tcr beta
sr and lr assays
all right so let's take a look at
where some of these solutions have been
used
so um first up is
study uh we did entirely
[Music]
which i'm going to talk about and more
details of the study can be
found in an upcoming webinar by my
colleague steve jackson
uh where he's going to talk um on talk
about how
tacman gene expression assays can be
used to
um to study any
uh gene signature in a tumor micro
environment
so why is this important we found that
um
uh there are a lot of applications in
which um
researchers are looking at genes of a
tumor micro environment
uh because they create a distinct
molecular profile
and uh the attackman gene expression
assays could be a great choice to look
at these
uh these genes in the microenvironment
so don't forget to tune in for that
webinar which is coming up
um and on the right uh you're looking at
uh data from uh
in uh in 2019
where uh the authors used tachman gene
expression assays to characterize
expression of various immune related
genes in dendritic and macrophages
uh cells in response to bmp4
and they found that this
information was critical um in
their ability to characterize the um
derivative macrophages differentiation
in acute lymphoblastic leukemia
so that's that's an example of where
attack mentioned expression assays can
be used
um next step is
uh microarrays so as i mentioned
microwaves we have
a couple of different panels um the more
uh
most useful in immune checkpoint and
mission
research are the therium db
which are
suitable for deep transcriptome analysis
coding and non-coding rna
as well as alternative splicing events
we also have
uh clarium sp glasses um which are uh
suited for gene level expression
profiling of well annotated genes
and both the uh clarium d and clarion
s assays have very high sensitivity and
um the entire transcriptome can be um
characterized in with as little as 100
picograms of rna
all right so coming to an example uh
or a case study um we looked at
a publication um in frontiers of
pharmacology
again in 2019 where um
the entire transcriptome uh was
characterized
in interest in response
to the effect of sphingosine kinase
in metabolic prostate cancer breast
cancer cells
and at the time of the study sphingosine
kinase both s
sk1 and sk2 were pretty well
characterized
proteins and there was a lot of
information already available as to
which pathways they belong to and
which pathways were up or down regulated
in response to
response to these
particular proteins however
uh this uh study revealed that
um pathways many pathways that
uh cross-linked with um suzanne kinases
were
uh either up or down regulated so
pathways such as
ras mapkey gtpas pik3 were upregulated
in response to
sk knockdown there are several other
pathways which
uh were traditionally known to be um
associated with cancer progression and
upper process such as
lt and prp not affected by skin
knockdown
so this kind of analysis where there's a
lot of um
interaction of pathways especially in
tumor progression
uh it's critical to be able to uh look
at the entire
genome or the entire transcriptome while
making decisions on
um which pathways may be affected
in response to a particular knockout
and cerium assays can can be a good tool
for for this analysis
all right so moving on to ngs
so with ngs we have um
of course the whole transcriptome
analysis
uh but we also have many targeted
sequences targeted targeted sequencing
panels
and one of them is um the iron torrent
oncoming immune response research assay
this is an assay which is a 395 genes
and uh they have been classroom selected
um because
these genes are known to be uh you know
involved with the immune response um
the tumor immune system interactions
right so all
three 95 and uh
what you're looking at here in the graph
is
expression levels of of a subset of
these 395 genes
across 10 pan cancer samples
and um the blue box plots refer
to genes that belong to the oncoming
immune response research assay
and you can see a pretty well spread out
uh
dynamic range of uh the
the genes as well as very these are
highly sensitive
and the gray bars um are
uh is data for
for the same sample from a competitor
platform so again um you know a nice
uh tool for a targeted uh sequencing
approach
all right so within uh our ngs toolkit
we have
um some other uh specific targeted
sequencing
panels one of them is the oncoming
tcr beta lr assay now this
uh assay is focused
uh and enables tcr sequencing
which is being considered as a possible
biomarker for
future immunotherapy responses and in
a study that was published in 2019
um in frontiers of immuno oncology
um uh the authors uh used
eye currency technology with um
so uh so the tcr beta um lsa
uh and found that um
they were able to um
sequence uh and accurately assess dcr
um coverage uh because
with the oncoming lr assay and they
especially noted that uh dcr convergence
may be
um they may be masked in other
sequencing technologies
and hence uh the choice of sequencing
platform uh
first this kind of research was uh very
important
right so these are some of the examples
that uh
we had for uh you know how our tools can
be used for checkpoint inhibition
research we will um now shift gears
to talk about therapeutic cancer
vaccines
so uh therapeutic vacuums
also can use a lot of tools that
were meant for indian checkpoint uh
inhibition research but in addition
um we also offer onco scan cnb assays
and the cytoscan
hd suite uh within the microarray
platform
um a lot of the pacman assay panels can
continue
can be used for therapeutic cancer
vaccine of course and a lot of the
um panels that i already mentioned in
ngs
including um the oncoming tcr beta
assays iron amplitude transcriptome the
exome
ionoplasty exon kit can be used for
cancer vaccines and of course um
almost all of these platforms also offer
uh custom panels which can be used for
you know to create your own custom
assays uh within a panel and study
all right so let's look at some exciting
work that was
let's done who the first reader can
vaccine using um
using our tools um so uh the heat map
that you see
uh to the left is from a publication
um in uh frontiers uh
in oncology uh from 2019
where uh the authors used uh applied by
system
clarium s mouse assay
to uh analyze the whole transcriptome
in neoclastic tissues and this analysis
led to the identification
of seven antigens which were highly
expressed in tumor cells
but not in normal cells
these seven antigens were then used as
targets for vaccine development
um in a similar study
are the authors of a publication from
2018
in uh journal of the statutory
expression it says to actually study the
effect
of uh addiction the mi3
um mip 3 alpha gp100
dna vaccine effect if it was
used to study and they found
that efficiency of this vaccine and vary
for the cancer vaccines
was dependent on tumorogenic factors in
the tumor micro environment
so again an example of you know how very
targeted
uh tools can be used for
such analysis right
um and then we have an example where
uh the iron torrent oncoming tcr beta
assay
along with the iron torrent oncoming
immune response research assay
was used to evaluate tcr conversions um
and this tcr convergence was used as a
potential bypasser
for response to their biotic or
peptide based vaccines um plant stage
melanoma
pretty neat uh all right so those are
the examples for
uh for therapeutic cancer vaccine
and next up is cartisol therapy
so just like um previously you know
we have solutions in both qpcr and ngs
but i do want to um point out that
we also have c-based
solutions for car t-cell therapy and
there's a
very neat study that was um published
um
published recently where the applied
biosystems
uh genetic analyzer 3500 genetic
analyzer was used to characterize
cd45 are a positive or negative um
negative and this was done because
cd45ra
is the investigated potential
marker for leukemic stem cells so a neat
form to characterize that molecule
um and in some of the other studies
we have clarium s assays
uh which were used for whole
transcriptome analysis
um and uh to characterize
uh you know cardi uh cells um and these
cells were um
characterized using clarium assassins uh
both before um a transplantation so
so when uh the cells are generated in
vitro they are
characterized as well as their progeny
after in vivo uh maturation
and uh the results give important
insights into differentiation of
uh the progenitor cells
um and are critical in making decisions
about you know successful
uh genetic entering of
uh cardi cells um
and finally the pacman gene expression
assays
have been used successfully to study the
validity of
b cell maturation so bcme is considered
a
novel car t cell marker and um
gene expression assays such as statement
gene expression assays could be
uh could be very useful tools and
studying the validity of
such antigens
all right so with that um i will come to
my
summary slide um and this is just again
a brief overview of
the different platforms uh we uh
covered in the course of this
presentation so we looked at
how a whole transcript migratory such as
sf can be used for whole transfer term
analysis depending on specific
applications um that we've seen you know
uh examples of how these were used for
checkpoint inhibition and
uh vaccine as well as well as a
characterization of car t cells
um qpcr assets of course we have a
plethora of qpcr asses which are very
well characterized and
um you know they can be uh useful tools
for discovery and
verification of checkpoint inhibitors
and other immune related genes
um as such as cytokines and chemokines
um so within the uh sangha sequencing
and
fragment analysis by uh capillary
electrophoresis platform
we have the seek studio genetic analyzer
and this can be very useful for tcr
sequencing
and um you know for analysis of
uh any sequences up to 700
um and coming to entry engines of course
we have a lot of
uh assays which can be used for immune
checkpoint
for uh immuno oncology research in
general um
we have uh the more targeted uh
sequences
are the immuno uh oncoming immune
response research assay
and the oncoming tcr beta lr assays
so um with that i
come to the end of this presentation
and i'm happy to take any questions that
might
be there on the call